China is reopening again after years of
covid-19 restrictions the country also
announced it will drop quarantine
requirements for international Travelers
this reopening for China has been the
biggest step they've taken after almost
three years of isolation in response the
U.S and several other countries want
travelers from China to show a negative
covid-19 test before entering that's
because China is facing a huge wave of
infections hospitals are overcrowded and
major outbreaks are spreading across the
country
so three years into the pandemic we'll
see a return of travel restrictions
here's what that means
China has largely been isolated from the
rest of the world since 2020.
but following Nationwide protests and a
steep economic slide Beijing removed
almost all of its testing lockdown and
quarantine measures including on
international travel starting January
8th people traveling to China will only
need to provide a negative covid-19 test
within 48 Hours of arrival this is a big
change from the last couple of years
when it's been 14 or 21 days even of
mandatory centralized quarantine but
covid-19 cases began to Surge soon after
restrictions were lifted and many
pharmacies in major cities ran low on
medication scientists say it's easy for
existing variants of the virus like
Omicron to spread quickly in a place
where few people had been previously
infected we've seen the virus spread
like wildfire across the country you're
seeing hospitals often get inundated
with covet patients particularly the
elderly and then you're also seeing like
Factory owners complaining because many
of their workers have been sick with
covid and it spread so quickly that very
often is like 30 or 40 percent of their
workforce out at one time for travelers
from China that means new challenges
when flying to other countries
the U.S India Italy and Japan were some
of the countries that immediately
imposed new restrictions for incoming
travelers from China
U.S health officials said China was
providing limited data on the surge I
think what governments and also other
health officials are concerned about is
that China might not be able to control
the spread of covid and from there there
might be new variants after
reintroducing covid testing on arrival
Italian officials said more than half of
the passengers on one of the first
flights from China tested positive the
Prime Minister wants mandatory tests
across the European Union
China has responded by calling for other
countries to prioritize the economic
benefits of travel
um
while countries continue to monitor for
developments more restrictions may be in
store for travelers coming from China I
think these travel restrictions are a
road bump but not a wall because people
have been locked down in China for
almost three years there's a huge
pent-up demand for travel globally a day
after China said that they would lift
the Border restrictions we saw trip.com
which is a huge travel provider in China
they were saying outbound travel
bookings were up almost 300 percent
because there's so much pent-up demand I
just don't see it as a very big
restriction at all